こんにちははじめ社長と
パグ日ですん
んだかじゃあ弊社 the 9月入ってしまいました
マイナーなん
うん
私は頭がウォッチは売ってんだよ
ん
[音楽]
はいというわけでは軽いこれ俺だけが押せないかわかんないんだけど
夏の終わりって
声腕が痛くなりませんわかりますこの想いが夏ってこう海とか
9蝉の声とか甘酸っぱい恋とかパー b 級とか夏祭り花火
そういうこうなんかすごい切ないというかスゴやっぱ
明るくてキラキラしてる終わりがすごい悲しいんですよわかるなぜのこのだけじゃ
なかっ客の時に夏の終わりっぽい悲しい bgm を聞いたら本当に泣けるんじゃない
かと思いますよ
フリー bgm がとしても多分今の僕なら聞けば泣けるようなぐらいの心臓の状態な
ので
僕は自分で見つけます僕も自分で抱ける bgm を見つけるです
のもて組も頑張って全部でちょっとだけそうな bgm 別の終わりの話し方は水63
月で僕に聞かせてくださいというわけで今日は皆も一緒に
な子それ本気でやばい俺マジなんですよそしてっ
[音楽]
tee
[拍手]
ハグしちゃうぞ
[音楽]
はいというわけでお互い曲がで捉えました月ですか
笑えない動画だと思うんだよし良かったらみなさんぜひねこの夏の終わり
デイたぶん皆さんも悲しいと思うんで話 bgm を聞いて一緒にちょっと切ない
気持ちになってくれたら嬉しいでございます
[音楽]
じゃあまず僕からちょっといいですか対局できますっていう苦悩するかなぁ風ジャブ
から入ろうかな
医局こちらです bbiq なんとかっていうサイトの end of summer
います
[音楽]
ああああああああ
あ
あーあ
へっ
二本の指の感じなのこれ
ano
なのに
持っていた
ちょっと切ない8
2項
ああああああ
ゲームのの曲の
楽しい神とかにあるようなちょっとそっぴ切なくなるようないわしたらでこれをついて
しました
ん
[音楽]
なきゃしねえな
花や愛想んって人も夏の思い出
います
me
あ
これいいぞ
おあなんか花火の情景が浮かびなあー
あーなんか夏っぽいなあああ
だーっくしゃみでちゃったけど
いい曲だなぁ
全部ケアーどうメロディーがとても
犬
アン眠くなってきちゃったいっ
me
[音楽]
[拍手]
なきゃしねーがー
[音楽]
厚木北行きますはい次はですね同じく動画シンドロームの
summer sky 夏空って曲につなげたらいいな
目指します
を
ポットっハッハー
あれあれプレちょっと泣き泣きそうだなぁーっとあーなんか浮かんできたなあああ
涙かにそんな南方さんのメダカでぞ
はぁ
なかった
いい天気の日の海ってイメージだなぁ
懐かしいなぁ実家にいる
犬を思い出すなぁ
もう死んじゃったけど
あれ
涙ってべちょっと泣きそうだ
ああああああ
サビが来るサビ学それが降っ
[音楽]
me
こんなもんか
持った
なきゃ死ぬ
[音楽]
曲面出さずになが住んで pt 外に出さないの後で言うよ
あの了解していきます
[音楽]
ああああああああ
これは
あーなんか思い浮かぶなぁ
コウキレイナス大草原という身近な
あ
あっああんっあっあっあちょっとああああなんかあああーなんかリゾート地って感じか
な
ああ
[音楽]
維持 no
こんな感じの服なんだけれどうーん
どんな線イメージしましたーー
これは海ブルーなんです
どんな pt がこんな他には
支援というか
これでしょ花火大会とかはかなり大会
るっぽいなー
ってこの曲の退去はなんですけど
雪の降り積もるよりに同様ございん
[音楽]
これはな方が多分いい感じかなー初恋という日ジムですっどうぞ
ビってなんなんだこの切ないメロディは
なんかすごい初恋って感じがすごい
なんだこの夏にカプレーゼをつないで海とか待つ人が入ったんだけども結局なんか
切ない感じで特に何もできないまま終わってしまったような切っても作りへ
付き合えなかったみたいなこの感覚たまらないサバランないよ
なにこれなにこれはぁ
いいなぁ
[音楽]
うーんだけ変わん
あつの恋では行きます
俺
ああ
内野この切ないメロディーわー
[音楽]
心に訴えかけてくるわなんやこれ
を
ええなあこのメロディ
これ
泣きそうやで
ほんま
[音楽]
ブーブー思えない何こんな絵チャいいところです
よかったと白いですね
竹辺はん
me
ああああああ
me あった
じゃあ僕ちょっとラストにもう医局あります
これなければ一番いいんですけどねん
ちょっと最後の夏の話曲ですお聴きください
八月の空へ
[音楽]
[拍手]
ん
me
こんな飛ぶ中そうやってるうんてもで決めたんですよ
だビジネスに柄者から